the three beat weave is perhaps the most
iconic and recognizable poy trick out
there and today we're going to talk
about how you can explore it in five
different levels of
[Music]
difficulty Drex here from Drex Factor
Poise sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I am here to
show you all the different ways that you
can turn a 3 beat weave in side out
upside down and everything in between
but before we dive in I just want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
meca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyrro light toys spinballs and
Ultra poy for helping them make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- buus friend
of the channel Becca beinen thank you so
very much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission the 3 beat weave is
a right of passage for po Spinners of
all different spinning Styles not only
is it eye-catching and distinctive but
it's also a really great challenge that
forces your brain to work in ways that
it doesn't usually and the 3B weave is
deceptively difficult there are many
variations on it that turn out to be way
more challenging than you might think so
in this video I'm going to take you
through five different levels of
difficulty with the 3B weave that are
going to test not just your physical
Acumen but your mental Acumen as well
starting with level one beginner the
three beat
weave so this is the classic that we all
know and love and generally one of the
first po tricks that anybody learns with
the prop the basic structure of the
three beat weave is relatively easy to
understand you're bending the plane of
the POI back and forth across your body
and doing so in such a way that you're
able to move one hand on top of the
other as you switch from side to side
the part of this that almost always
trips people up as they're learning it
of course course is that we're not
performing an even number of Beats on
each side of the body doing a beat on
each side is pretty easy to learn but
performing an extra beat on the opposite
side of the body that can take some
training the pattern that's usually
taught to beginners is to think of these
beats as the location that they have
relative to the other hand over under
back over under back and the same
Arrangement is going to be important for
nearly every other trick on this list
too if this is a trick that isn't in
your wheelhouse just yet that's totally
fine I created a tutorial on how to do
it that I'll go ahead and link to down
in the description or up in the cards if
you're watching on YouTube level two
beginner intermediate the Archer weave
so believe it or not if you can already
perform a 3B weave you have all of the
prerequisite knowledge necessary to
perform an Archer weave too it's kind of
crazy to think that this move is
basically the same one that we just
covered the only difference is we're
changing where the point of contact is
between our two hands rather than
touching each one to each other's wrists
as they go over under back instead we're
placing in one at the shoulder and the
other one is stretched all the way out
part of what makes this variation on the
3B weave so eye-catching is that it
takes a move that can be performed just
as easily in wheel or wall plane and
places it definitively in wall plane
opening up the amount of volume that the
trick takes up somehow the Archer weave
actually manages to add even more
Dynamics to a PO move that was already
stunning to watch the one thing to keep
an eye out for keep that hand that's
back at your shoulder as close to the
shoulder as possible for as clean a
presentation of this trick as you can
Poss possibly get all right so the 3B
weave and the Archer weave are both
pretty standard now let's get into some
really weird stuff level three
intermediate the alien weave so this is
a concept that alien John demonstrated
many years ago wherein you could
basically turn the 3B weave into an
asymmetric weave and take half of a five
beat weave and half of a two beat and
somehow still wind up with three beats
in the end if you know how to do a 5B
weave this concept isn't actually that
hard to get down it just kind of breaks
your brain because all of a sudden
you're no longer trying to get the same
moves on each side of your body that you
were before and yes technically it does
still count as a 3B weave we are still
doing the thing where we're switching
which hand is on top each time and it
just so happens to be that we're piling
most of the Beats on one side of the
body this may seem a little more than an
idle curiosity but I actually think that
it is a great tool for understanding how
to do 5 beat weaves as well as how to
add and remove beads in meteor weaves
though it looks pretty strange and more
than a little bit lopsided there is
actually a point to getting down this
technique and don't worry it only gets
weirder from here cuz we're about to go
into inversion land level four
intermediate to Advanced The buz saww
Weave yes believe it or not this is
still technically a 3B weave it's just
kind of been turned inside out so the
key here is that we're kind of changing
our benchmarks rather than thinking that
the pattern is over under back we're
thinking over under in between this
means that our home base is no longer
with the poy on each individual side of
our body but with the PO in between our
hands I know in some respects this seems
like cheating but it really makes sense
if you think about 3B weave in the
context of how one hand's poy is related
to the opposite hand that is when I'm
doing a three beat weave thinking over
under back if I'm thinking of all that
in terms of the right hand Poise
relationship to the left hand well the
buz saww weave does all of that this was
actually the first poy trick that I ever
encountered that truly broke my brain
Christian Medina showed this to me way
back in 2008 when we met in New York
City and it took me years to understand
what was going on here though I rarely
see people performing this style of move
anymore I still think that it's a great
way to get a more advanced understanding
of three beat weaves and to understand
all the ways that we can tweak the
variables of them to come up with things
that look completely and radically
different all right so before I show you
our final level of difficulty here I
have a favor to ask if you've come this
far it probably means that you're really
into po spinning and poy tricks and
guess what I make lots of videos on
those topics so if you wouldn't mind
please subscribe to the channel so that
way you know right when I drop a new
video and without further Ado our final
level of difficulty level five Advanced
the introverted weave okay so this one
is definitely going to take some
explanation again the pattern here
technically conforms to that of the
three beat weave but we're making a
choice here that the poy whenever they
perform one of these beats have to do so
in between the arms that means that
whenever the PO is swinging forward it's
doing so just past the elbow of the hand
that is connected to and I kind of love
the way this weave looks if for no other
reason than it forces the planes into an
atomic orientation so it's a move that
you can get a clear view of no matter
what perspective you happen to be at it
also forces the body to explore the
volume around it just a little bit more
you have to force your elbows out away
from your body rather than keeping them
lodged up against your sides like you
would in a traditional 3B weave and at
least in my mind part of what makes this
move so fascinating is that it's kind of
the opposite of the Archer weave that is
where the Archer weave tries to eat up
as much volume as possible an
introverted weave kind of tries to eat
up as little volume as possible it's so
cool that we have so much range with
this one type of poy trick so there you
go friends how many of these variations
of the three beat weave do you know
leave me a comment and let me
[Music]
know
thank you so much for watching this
video friends uh it would not exist
without the wonderful support of all of
my patreon supporters in particular I'd
like to give a shout out to my flow
patrons who are listed on screen now um
if you dug this video and you'd like to
check out more list videos that I've
done on different py tricks I will
include a link to a playlist of those
down in the description uh and if you'd
like to support the channel I will also
include a link to my patreon down there
thanks so much in advance for checking
those out please make sure to get out
and flow today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon take care now peace